we are backstage at Good Morning America
about to officially launch Oscar road
trip so very excited for two reasons
really one we're about to launch a
nationwide trip to bring the magic of
the Academy Awards to the American
public and to raisin bagels very tasty
we went all over New York today in a
very short amount of time I don't wanna
be the Oscar
thanks my dad my mom needed to have this
done more motion this is the greatest
moment of my entire life
and thank you in New York was amazing
did some fun things and brought some
great Oscar experiences to people I wish
I had one day three Philadelphia big
success today I think Oscar was met with
just so much enthusiasm
and the Oscar fan experience goes to
Jessica to Chia today was our nation's
capital
the Oscar does not have a comment about
that okay
wow this is heavy being in theater in
high school you're like oh my god old
Oscar we're giving you two tickets to
the Oscar fan experience
following you guys on Twitter in the
thought that you're going to be in
Baltimore today they take the whole
thing off work when my best friend lives
in Charlotte I live here in Baltimore
and we have a tradition that we're
always together for the Oscars so we
applied to do with each other your
friend never never tried to get
completed
oh we try to make part of what we've
been doing along the way here is that
you know me fans like you to love it and
once in a while we can do things like
send you to the bleacher seats on the
red carpet for the Oscar fan experience
yeah it's not a joke nice know where
you're going you're going to the Oscars
we're here at Charm City Cakes in
Baltimore I'm a national cake the cool
thing is the cake
oh my god Sarah hood we're told you're
beloved this is the Oscar road trip and
we're very excited to visit with you
guys thanks so much for your service
hey I'm walk-in here with an awesome
you got that right